[Music]
hi everyone
welcome back to another vjs stream on
free code camp
hi sassy it's good to see you again hi
tom
so today is a continuation
of the last app
basically last week's app which was this
view nwjs hours tracking app
and i'm going to post this in the chat i
think it's in the description below too
let me oops there we go
all right so i was basically building
this application to track hours
in vue.js so you can still watch the
last stream and you can also read the
readme here there's some more
details about it so basically i made a
couple screens
last week um got the
front a lot of the front end started
anyway
and so today i would like to be able to
set up
some kind of a database solution and
then
finish setting up some more of the
screens
in the application and just real quick i
looked through
quite a few solutions that people use
for databases
for desktop apps over the last few days
and it's quite different because i'm so
used to
you know attaching the database to a
backend
and from the front end calling an api
or even doing a full stack application
together like a django app
but there's a distinct front end and
back end but
in desktop apps it seems like it's
recommended
to just call called because it's all
compiled into
an application anyway so um i don't have
to differentiate between the front and
back end as much it's okay to
i guess call the database from the front
end
and so out of all the options pouchdb
looked really good so this is the one
i'm gonna
work with today for the application
i also set up this is uh comes from
couchdb
so i set up couchdb
earlier just to check it out because i
hadn't used couchdb before
but i used dynamo and [ __ ] and a couple
other i would say similar
databases yeah so
um that was the starter for this app
so i have the code open and
i'm going to go ahead and run the code
with the
npm start command
and this should open my browser window
for the nwjs application
all right cool
so this is what i did last time
this is all in bootstrap by the way
and i have this page is the hours log
and then i have a projects page
uh there's no canada project that was
just the default
from this drop down component that i
added oh
add new project isn't set up yet but i
do have this ad
entry for the hours log where you can
add a new hours entry
um so i think i'm going to start off
trying to
for this hours log i'm going to start
off trying to save this
in a database and figuring that part out
so i'm going to come to
pouch db skip
bower um okay so npm
i'm not going to use the node because i
can just use it directly for my view app
here
so i'm gonna go ahead and install
pouchdb
um oh right i have to stop it anyway
oh well so let me get this installed on
first
okay and then just in my html
i can require
db and i shouldn't have to do anything
else
okay and then i'll have to set up the
database so i guess i'm going to do this
in my main.js file in the view
application
that's still installing
can everyone hear me okay
um oh let's see
source so in my main js file
um oh here's the public so here's my
index.html file
which is
let's see build files will be
auto-injected so i can add this
in the header okay cool hi oliver
i think this is the first time i've seen
you here welcome to the stream
so let me just add the db
here in the head tag
above anything that's going to be
injected
and above the view app
um okay
so now it says
working with local databases to create
local database you can simply call new
patchdb
and give it a name so
this is what i'm going to do
rdb equals new pouchdb
and i think i'll put that in my main js
file for right now
and then i can separate it later
so i'll say pouch db
config let me zoom in one
where's the drag there it is
okay pouch db
config
okay so this is my new db i won't call
it kittens though
i'll call it hours
for hours
tracking
let me do this camel case
okay so i have a new db instance and
then
okay it says live code example pro tip
whenever you see
this live example in the guide you can
download it just to follow along at home
for example
to run this app okay i don't want to do
that
how to oh remote databases
and give it a path to a database in
couchdb
i don't think i want to do that although
i do have couchdb running right now just
in case
get basic info about the database
working with databases
okay and then oh interesting so i can
um all right let me run my app i think
with the dev tools oh npm start
i think i'll be able to navigate through
this database
using the in browser dev tools
the same ones i use in chrome or firefox
okay so that's loading let me try to
open
the
dev tools let's see
inspect
so okay not in source
let's see is it in
i can't remember which one application
sources why am i i'm having a brain fart
right now i can't remember
yeah here it is application all right
so indexeddb
um i'm not using index db
cache storage application cache local
storage
um okay i thought maybe it would be in
here but i guess i need to read a little
bit more
let's see indexeddb web sql inspectors
you can use the normal developer tools
to see what your database looks like
under the hood
in chrome just choose the overflow icon
tools developer tools then click on
resources tab
then indexeddb okay
tools developer tools
all right so
oh these are the developer tools
resources tab
do i have a resources tab
um more tools
yeah i don't see it okay i mean index db
is here anyway
so this is probably what they're talking
about
but yeah i don't see it there
so maybe it just hasn't added the
database yet
so okay
um so i have this
which is a new db hours tracking
and seems to be doing okay
yeah there's nothing to add right now so
how do i
add a table or a collection to the
database
um you can also enable
debug logging oh wait what am i doing
i'm not importing pouchdb from
oh yeah i am it's in my index.html file
okay nevermind
so i have my pouchdb database
and so i should be able to
let me enable the debug mode
put that here
okay delete your local
database
in chrome you can use clear cache all
right
um debug mode
i wonder if it's in working with
documents
so patchdb is a nosql database yeah
okay so to store a document you simply
use put
um okay so
db.get mittens
okay so there i think there is no
concept of tables
in this database it's just
put the documents
and then retrieve them by the id okay
well um
this is interesting
okay i think what i'm going to do first
then
is finish up some of these pages just so
i can get going with this
and then work on putting things in the
database so
i think i'm going to pick back up on the
projects page where i was here
and make it so you can add a project
because i'm going to need a foreign key
relation between
these projects and which hours or
which project certain hours go to
so i think i'm going to finish setting
up that so select projects
i need an add new project page
which will match this schema here so
i'll need a name description
color and then
create it at updated should be automatic
so
i need a name description and a color
for the project
so the first thing i need to do is
create a view for that
get out of here in my
source so i have app
which is oh wait this is the
wait one second
i think that was a different let me open
this in the code editor make sure that's
the right app
there we go all right
so yeah i was wondering where my views
folder was
okay so here's the projects page
that i have and i have the time entry
page which is the form
for entering new hours so i'm going to
copy that
and i'll go to views and
now i'm going to put i guess project
entry page
since i'm calling the other one time
entry and i'm going to paste
this let's see what i need to change
not time entry but project
entry
and okay i don't need
date pickers for this
and okay i have submit and reset buttons
so i need to grab
form elements for this oh and let me
change the page name
to project entry
uh start date end date
okay so i have a basic boilerplate for
it
um oh yeah let me add it to the router
real quick so i can wrap to that page
add time entry so let me copy
this go to the end
and this one will be add
project
project entry okay now i need to import
this
at the top um
project entry project
entry okay so now i have
it routable so let me go to
my hours log
or not my hours log um
okay in my app
no actually it's from the projects page
it's not from the main bar
so this here this add new project
so let me
just create a link from here
and say
at click and then i'm going to use the
view router
so dollar sign router
dot push and then whatever
route so actually i could do
based off the name so i could do name is
project entry let's see if that works
oh i need to run it again so npm
start and that'll take a minute
okay so now project entry
is routable and then
yeah the database is really the next
thing because i need to be able to add
these hours and projects in here
so from the hours log if i add an
entry from here
okay cool i can add a project
entry let me just add those fields real
quick and then i'll get back to the
database
so name description and color and
from okay from here
i have these label start date so this is
going to be
name and then
add description
and then
i'll add color
and i'm using vidif not beautify
this is bootstrap
okay let me look up bootstrap view then
for the forum elements
bootstrap view
here we go
okay uh get oh docs here we go
so let me look for form
and i think just all the form components
are on one page
here so
where is the code here it is so this b
form
b form group b form input so this is
what i want
b form input
and then so the first two name and
description are these inputs
let's see
this one will be type of text
which is default so i don't think i need
it there required
placeholder is
name and
v model is form data
and then i'll put name which i don't
have there yet so name
id is okay and now let me just copy this
actually i'll probably want a text area
so let me search for that
form text area
yeah let me copy this one it's a form
text area
okay b form input now i have
text area i think this is actually
zoomed in too much
maybe yeah that's better it was
sideways scrolling a lot
okay
so the model is
is it form data dot description
and then i'll say enter a description
for the placeholder three to six rows
that's fine
um and then
oh yeah i'm not closing it that's why it
was giving me an
error okay cool
that looks good i wonder if you can
resize things
oh not really in this that's fine so i
have a
name description and then i need a color
picker
so let me look for
color picker i wonder if they have one
they have bar color schemes
color picker
those date pickers oh here's color
picker it's a third party library i
guess
view color picker v color vert
view color picker
do i want to add a whole color picker
um
yeah it looks pretty easy to use let me
look at the other ones
oh you can zoom panes independently in
vs code i didn't know about that
um pretty sure
there's an html native color picker
um is there html
an html color picker oh wait
color picker
type color oh
it only works in modern browsers well
good thing this is latest version of
chromium
um okay
color picker
let's see
actually i don't need the name because
i'm gonna remodel this so i guess i can
do
v model is
form data dot color
type color oh cool
thank you i didn't even know i didn't
even know html had one
and that looks just as good as any other
one
except i can change the style a little
bit of how it's displayed
thank you okay let me just put these in
my data real quick
so i need name
description
and then color which
i guess it's a string i'm not sure
um
let's see let me actually see
what it is let me open up the dev tools
inspect
and i think i have view yeah i have the
view dev tools here
so let me look at
um let's see project
entry yeah cool i have the color there
thank you that was easy all right so now
i have
project entry page and the hours log
and add new time entry page so now i
really need to hook this up to the
database
and i think my mind just being so used
to
let me get rid of these um you know
having it connected to a back end
it's it's kind of strange to i guess
imagine this database or imagine how to
use it
okay so related api documentation
there's get and there's put and i'm
guessing get
because i'm gonna need to get back
or query for a whole bunch of objects of
the same
yeah you did thank you
i'm going to need to query for a whole
bunch of objects
of the same type so
i guess i can pass in options let me
look at their examples
so they have db.get
my doctor okay let's stop then um but
that's just searching by id
how can i pull things back without using
the id
okay create update a batch of documents
that's good
okay db.bulk docs
so i i'd have to create a different
database for
i think i need one database for projects
and one database
for users with this
with pouchdb
okay bulk update delete
what about bulk get oh fetch a batch of
documents
db all docs fetch multiple documents
indexed and sorted
by the id
uh deleted documents are only included
if option.keys is specified okay
so i basically
need to set up two databases
oh i was wondering why the database
didn't show up it's because i put it in
the wrong application
that was that was dumb um
okay so here i'm actually going to have
to
um
go back i think it's working with
databases
yeah i need this and then i need to set
up the debug too
so i have all of these imports
all of those okay i'm going to set up
database config here and
two databases and then i need to set up
the debug options
you can also enable debug logging by
doing
this i want logging because i want to
make sure that it's working
okay so kittens what other
so these are i think it the concept of
db here is like a table
so i'm gonna do
time entry
and then
was the other one projects
or this would be time entries
and
let's see deleting your local database
differences between local and remote
okay
and now oh i'm not
actually importing this in this app
into the index.js so let me go into
public
go to index.html i mean
and then i need to paste the link there
which is setting up pouchdb
i already installed it so i just need to
add this link to the head tag
oh hi jared good to see you
too bad you're here not here to help me
with nwjs
okay so let's see
script tag pouch cb
and i think that's it let me rerun the
server because i'm
guessing i'll need to rerun it so
it can see that import in the index.html
all right now it's going to reopen the
window
uh maybe there's an error i don't know
let's see pouchdb is not defined
okay
um so i have it here
um because i thought that it would
expose oh
not enough in that file from here
i thought that it would expose
that pouch db variable for me to use
but i guess it's not doing that
so i could i guess i could do it just
directly npm
install it wait someone sent me a
message
uh nw dot window dot
okay just to automate the devtools
opening
sure let me add that thanks for the tip
um let me add this to
i guess just anywhere for right now
um i'll have to take that out before i
build this as an app
okay so i guess next time i
next time i run my server it should
automatically open the devtools
the first line of js and then comment it
out
okay pouchdb is not defined
so
let me actually take this out i'm gonna
try
oh it did restart patch tv is still not
fun i know
let me actually install it just like i
would any other
view module here and
uh let's see mpm and
oops i copied npm install okay npm
install pouchdb
and it's taking a minute
yeah that'll just be easier if i can
import it
in view okay
yeah i don't know why i didn't do that
before now let me do
npm start and while that's going
i'll come to my main js and
i'm gonna put that with my library
imports
08 require i wonder if i can import this
then
um db
uh import pouch db
i'll see if this works
from pouch db
cannot read enable of undefined
in my
source main js
oh dot pouchdb.debug.in
okay so i wonder if it's even
registering
pouch db because i don't seem to have
the
debug enable available so let me look in
application
oh cool i do have it awesome
so i do have if you can see on the side
there i have pouchdb
projects and patchdb time entries
and then i can open those up
and um
i can look at all the different
i don't know i'm not too familiar with
um
the index to db in the browser so
yeah i'll have to try that out okay but
anyway
i do have my two
databases here that i added that's good
so i should be able to start
adding things to them
so how do i do
let's see i can do
create update doc create database delete
yeah let me go to create or update so
it's just db.put
and then um
[Music]
i need the
doc okay um so
here i have
the two dbs here i have time entries and
projects
the thing is though i'm wondering
if i should put it here now i'm thinking
that maybe i want this
in my view x or in an extra config that
i import into my view x
because
this is really where i'm going to be
working with
that db stuff
so let's see
let me make not in my router in my store
let me make a new file and i'm going to
call it db
config dot js
and then i'm going to take pouch db
uh take it here is this a good idea
does anyone else have a better idea set
it up in my view
x and then
i'm going to take these
because otherwise i mean could i inject
it into
my global state but then i want to use
it from view x
so i need access to those databases from
here anyway oh wait i made this new file
let me use that new file
um okay
so let me use that file and then let me
import import db
config from
db config
okay and now i need to
um export oh wait this is these are both
the bees
why am i doing two dbs so let me export
these as two different things
i'm gonna do um
t e db
no i need to spell this out so time
entry
db and
i'll call this projects
db and actually that should be time
entries
okay and then from here i need to export
something
so i need to export
export um
yeah i was thinking i could export these
individually
but i want to export an object because
then i can
add options or do whatever i want
so let me export default
in object and i'll do time
entries eb
and then i'll do projects db
okay um
oh it has the option to refresh that's
cool
okay so now i have these two database
instances and i can pull these out
so when i import them into view x
i can just go ahead and get time entries
and projects
db and then i can do whatever i want
with them in my
view x store and then i can interact
with the database from any component
through the store
okay um so i think i think that will
work
and now let me do db.put
doc options callback
um so let me grab this
and let me just do a test here so
let me do
um okay so doc
i need name
gwen and then
options uh
options i'll just leave an empty object
for that
and then callback function
um this will be just console.log
worked even though there's no
error handling
all right so how do i see
documents that i've added which one did
i add to oh i don't even have db there
let me add this to time entries oh no
projects
projects db
um export projects db was not found in
db config okay
exports projects
db okay so
let's see projects db did i misspell
something
i think i misspelled something
did i
oh it seems to be right projects db
let me restart the server and see
okay these are both new pouchdb
projects dp
okay export project stevie was not found
in db config learning from
source store index.js
hmm
that's weird okay let me look at
index.js
see if i'm importing the right file so i
do have
db config which is that file name
and then i'm importing let me try time
entries
yeah why why aren't the exports being
found in here
i'm exporting default oh because i'm
requiring
this maybe um
maybe i need to import
let's see import
from i think this i feel like that's
what i was doing anyway in
the main.js file
no i thought i had it here where i
changed it to import maybe i didn't i
can't remember
okay it was not found
in
let's see it wasn't found in
the dbconfig file so let me actually see
because this is creating the new
pouchdb instances and
i am exporting the correct
um values from there
so that's a little bit strange let me
see
um time entries projects db
exports um let me see what
these are equal to from here
so
let me try to get it to pause
on the debugger okay so
um entries db
these are both correct and pouch db
those are both correct
and then what i'm exporting is also
correct
which is strange okay
but then when i'm importing it so the
problem is when i'm
importing it here and i can do
a debugger here
that should restart on its own does
anyone have an idea about why this isn't
working
let's see
it's restarting cannot read property
line number
of undefined
okay let me play it
and
maybe i'll restart the server again
and this should open the
dev tools so it should open the new
debugger i think
because the devtools will open before
the app
finishes
okay so i have my two index db's
i'll refresh both of them
console.log inside of export okay so
here's the problem cannot read put of
undefined
um but these are defined
console.log so inside of export
um i looked at these in the debugger
and when i had a debugger in here
where is it get out of there in here
let's see and
it says that they're defined here
or at least it shows time entries but it
was saying in the other file that time
entries and projects aren't defined
which is weird i can make sure that this
one
yeah these are all spelled the same
let me step over oh yeah
try pudding okay let's
try putting inside of
try put inside of db config yeah i guess
it will work from there maybe i'll just
move it to this main file
because it doesn't seem to like the
importing exporting and that might
because
because it's only set up it's not set up
to use
es6 but i don't see how that would make
sense
because this import works yeah i don't
know
let me see oh wait did i
let me get this back
and now in here
okay so time entries db.put
and then let me see i got rid of all the
debuggers so let me just play
cannot read property put of undefined
let me
refresh this okay
okay so that worked actually if i just
have it in the same file
yeah i don't know why the import export
isn't working
why do you need the curly brackets in
import
oh i was just pulling these two things
out
from the import
so i didn't have to but then i would
have to
do like db dot this database or that
database
so i was just using a shorthand
um okay
maybe you should import yeah that's what
i'm thinking that i'll just move this
whole thing to import for right now
because this seems to work i do wonder
how i can see
so that's time entries um
[Music]
attach store local store
meta store this is metadata
doc id sequence
there's a lot of stuff in here
so where is
um
i wonder do i have to refresh this
database
refresh
because i can't see the dock i just
added
it's not listed here
key blob
detect blob support yeah i don't know
where the document is
i guess i don't know enough about this
index.js
to see it but it says it saved so
let me just move this to the index file
yeah and
so um let's see
get rid of that export default get rid
of these
okay and i wonder if i do have to set an
id here
so let's look at a document
yeah they're putting the id so i do need
to set my own id
on these documents so i guess i'm going
to use uuid
let's see npm uuid
to generate a unique id for each
document since the database isn't doing
it for me
okay npm install uuid
and then i'll import it into the view x
okay one more time stopping the server
oh clear um
npm install uuid
that should be pretty quick and then i
can import
um uid okay then i just call the uuid
function
so let me import this in my view x
so after pouchdb
i'll import um
version 4 as uuid version 4.
so i think this is how i need to
store documents in here i need to add
the database
so i can call this uuid function that i
just imported
and save the id and name
[Music]
and i'm actually logging worked here so
i think that's oops um
oh wait that's also a mistake
so
let's see
because this could come back with an
error
so um
what would i get response and then error
or error and then response
let me look at this api
uh okay so oh there's dot then dot
catch after put so i could use async
await for this
and then try catch let me just copy this
though
for this test right here so
i'm going to do this so i'm going to
call that put
and now i can use dot then
indent all this all right
hi pk get now how are you
um okay so now i have error and i'll
just
console.log the
response as well
okay and let me see how it handles this
when i run the app again
npm start
hi pk did you join to give me some
advice
um
hopefully but if you want to chat that's
good too
um okay
i like the dev tools opening
automatically
all right
yay sweet look at this doc id
rev whatever that means
and i have the
object with named gwen
i have the unique id that i set
primary key one cool
okay so now i can see it in here that's
good news
and now i just need to
put this in my um
or add view x
actions here
oh sorry my watch is telling me to go
walk around
it says it reminds me when i've been
sitting too long
but i can't walk around right now um
okay so actions what kind of actions do
i need i need to
i need crud operations for
projects and for time entries
so i'm gonna name these kind of like
crud operations so let's say
create time entry
um these will all be async too
so
and then we do async create
project
and then
in create time entry i'm gonna
copy this
uh wait oh yeah
oh i missed the other part of
the there we go
so what i'm going to do inside of this
async function is change this
from promises to async await
so i'm going to do const
const response equals
a weight whatever object i'm going to
put in
and actually here so
the first parameter is
um from vue.js so i'll be able to
get the function to commit mutations and
then the second one is what i'm passing
in as the payload
which will be in
object here which will be this object
that i'm gonna save
um so let me get rid of this then
and i'm gonna add the payload on here
and i'm going to generate an id from
view
x for that payload i'm passing in that i
want to save
as a time entry um
okay and then get rid of
bees
it keeps bringing me over there every
time i save but it's such a habit to
save
every second um
okay i feel much better about this now
let's see um create time entry
so this i need to wrap this in a try
catch
so i can know if this creates an error
let me close that and then do catch
let's see error
and then i'll just do console.
error and error
and now okay in my try
i need to so what do i want to do with
the response
um
the response
i don't know i guess for now i could
just log it out i actually don't think i
want
um because this is
all local so because in a nor
so in a normal vjs application on the
web i would
take the document i just created and
push it into my state so that i didn't
have to make another api call
but and actually that will make it
update so let me just
not do that for right now and see how
this plays out so let me do console.log
response
um and that means it was a success so
let me do
i guess success
okay and then i basically want the same
thing
for
create project so i'm just going to go
ahead and put that and then i'll make a
getter because i need to be able to get
all of this stuff out of the database
so for project i want the same things
i want i probably don't need to commit
so i'll just leave that
empty um i don't know if i can leave it
empty
um maybe i don't know uh payload
is that gonna error and
i wonder so okay so this is project
projects db
which is basically the same thing um
generating uid passing the payload
so i save all of the key value pairs on
the payload
and then so now i need to get all of the
items that i save
so let me make that real quick before i
test out the saving
because i need to be able to see if i
created anything
hi jared so i basically
several things broke but i think they're
fixed now
i basically set up pouchdb from here
because i couldn't get it working
from importing in the
index.html file and then
i have to create my own ids so i
imported uuid
um yeah and then i have these two
databases
so patchdb seems to differentiate
by databases instead of tables so i
created two different databases for
these two tables that i want
and right now i'm working on these
actions so that i can get
uh get all the time entries
and projects that are in the database
line 18 yeah i'm still typing
that's why there's an error
okay
yeah let's see uh read
time entries okay
um i don't actually need to commit from
there either really
so let me do i don't need to pass in a
payload
i don't need anything
um i just need to basically get which is
oh bringing me back over there so i
think
that is bulk get or batch
is it batch fetch
oh indexes and everything okay
um let's see batch fetch
db.all docs okay
so from here then
i'll have to be able to filter at some
point too
which i guess options might let me
filter
i forgot to have water here i might need
some in a second
um okay so
what was i getting oh yeah db.all docs
so let me do that here so await
db which will be
time entries db dot
all docs and then
pass in options if i want options
but i think i don't don't need options
right now so let me
do const docs
equals that and let me just i guess i'll
log out the docs because i don't know
what format that's coming back in
okay and now i need this action to
be able to be called from my component
which will be my hours log so i can see
all the hours in here
so let me go down here and i'm going to
map it into the component
so i'm going to import
was it map actions
from view x
can you explain commit
yeah so real quick commit
here is um
so view x has my global state or it will
have global state
whenever i need state that doesn't
necessarily need to be in the database
but i want it to be accessed by many
components
so what commit does is call a mutation
that can update that global state but
right now i don't have any mutations
um or anything on the global state so i
really don't need commit
yet but it's generally from ux actions
most viewers bux actions will call
commit
to update state but i'll get rid of that
for right now so it's not yeah
so it's not there when i don't need it
um
oh yeah
uh okay so i am pulling in
map actions and now i need
so i need to put that in methods which
will be below data so i need a methods
object for view
and then
i can do map actions call that
and then which actions do i want to map
to this component
i want read time entries
i can't get rid of that um
yeah read time entries create no i don't
need that one here so just read time
entries basically
and now i need or i need to call read
time entries so this will be called on a
created
so let me add my life cycle hook here
created
so when this component
actually no i'll do mounted so when this
component mounts
to the screen it should
[Music]
call my action
uh which is this dot
read time entries now
and then i don't need to pass anything
in so
i can do this.readtime entries
which we'll call this and then it should
lock up log out my docs
so let me see if that works
sweet why does it say two rows
oh i must have uh
saved it twice saved something twice
where's my name in this
okay that's weird it seems like it's
just an id
and nothing else that i saved all right
that's fine so anyway that's coming back
with docs
and that
is yeah so i'll need to do rows
so docs is this whole object and then i
need to do dot rows
so that's kind of like response.data
so let me then do
um so here's actually where i need a
mutation
because i need to update the docs here
so let me commit a mutation from here
and i'll need to
do what is it set
i guess set time entries
and then pass in docs dot rows
and then in
state so state i need to have all
time entries
okay and then i i guess i'll also oh
that will be an array actually
so that's an array and then i need
projects here
which i'll need in a minute and that's
also an array
and then i need to create that mutation
that i'm calling so set time
entries needs to be a mutation which is
not async
inside a mutation i have access to state
and i have access to whatever i'm
passing in
which is the i like to use the word
payload
i don't know how many people use that
but it's just like a general word
for anything that i'm passing in
so now i can do this
no i don't need this because i already
have state available to me in the
function
so now i can overwrite state
on time entries
which is equal to the payload that i'm
passing in
oh commit is not defined i forgot to
import
or get commit in the function so here i
need
commit
that should work now let me look at my
view
um
where is it here it is oh cool it called
the mutation set time
entries and now
i have the payload with two objects
which is weird i'm gonna have to figure
that out
but anyway it did work and
so that is my store now i have an array
of time entries
cool
so now i need to be able to create one
create time entry from the
time entry dot view page
i like payload it sounds very serious
does it what is payload in the military
oh this like dropping a bomb or
something
that's that's kind of gruesome that
makes me not want to use the bird
anymore
um okay so i have dates here
okay okay i get it i get it um
so when i click submit i'm going to
call this action that i need to be
getting from view x
so here also i'm going to have to
import
[Music]
map actions from
view x and
i'm trying not to save after every time
because it switches me back to the other
screen
um okay oh yeah methods now i need to
do math actions and
which action do i want it's create time
entry
oops and
now i can call this
dot create time entry and then i need to
pass it
a payload of what i want to create which
is
form data so actually
i can just pass it as an object here
because that's what my payload is
expecting
so i can do
this dot form data
um oh yeah but how am i doing start date
and date i'll have to look at how i'm
saving those
um in what format but this is okay just
to get this working for now
um so let me go to add
time entry choose
uh today
choose today and then end date
after some hours submit
okay i might have to do prevent default
there let me see if it
did add anything
i think i have to go back to this page
because this is where it loads the hours
company one no that was just that was
already there never mind
um
so let me look at this state here
yeah it did add it though value
set time entries
why is it not showing
the actual value here
i guess that's um
let me refresh this let me refresh this
database refresh
and so here okay i do see start date and
date
all right and
these are
time stamps okay actually i can
bring the value over here
okay that's actually pretty good i have
start date and date that's exactly what
i want
um then why am i doing this i think what
i need to be doing here is actually
having a string
not an object i think that's
from something i had before
okay so now i can create i can pull them
from the database
um i could loop through these actually
in my hours log
kalachi factory um
oh i missed okay um
talking about food makes me hungry what
was i doing i can't remember
oh yeah hours long i want to loop
through these and display them
in the table so be table
striped hover and then
items it's kind of a really simple table
i want to denote like which
i guess which headers i want um well let
me map state to this component
i want to get those time entries off of
ux
so map
state to the component
and now i need to create computed here
so that i can see the updates that
happen in my view x state
and let me do map state here
and what state do i want to map
[Music]
here it is so
my state is i have this array of time
entries that i want to map here
so now i can see all the time entries in
this component
and then i could
on this table here i could just pass in
time entries
and see how it looks
that looks awful um
yeah why aren't i getting the correct
values back i guess
from the database i'm doing this wrong
so let me see
deleted documents are only included
oh okay i need to do include docs
thanks options not include docs i need
to set this to true because otherwise i
just get the id
and i i guess rev is for revision
and that changes when i update it i'm
guessing
um okay so options.include docs
so i need to set this
in no in my
database um
in my get so here
um so is it an array
yeah it's an array of options
so how does that look
okay no it's an object i'd pass it yeah
it would be weird as an array
i guess they were just using brackets as
a placeholder there
okay so
include docs is true
[Music]
is true any other options i want
attachments are attachments
include that as okay so those are like
images and stuff
uh maybe i want that sure
um actually i don't need that here so
maybe i'll do that when i actually have
images like on the profile or something
okay so now
okay now i have the doc
and i'm going to need to
yeah i'm going to need to clean up this
database a little bit
but what was i oh yeah in the code
so i have this and i'm setting docs.rows
and let me see what docs.rows are
i guess it's docs.rows.dock i have to do
it
let me see what it said as time entries
now
so oh dot value
no dot value is already there i need
this
i need doc
rose.doc
okay and now i get nothing
let me undo that and
let me it might be easier if i just
console.log out these
docs dot rows
so i can explore them
okay so let me take document one
and this is what i want i want
um oh right right that was dumb
so i want the documents here so i'm
going to pass in
actually to my mutation i'm going to
pass in docs.rows and then
in my mutation
and i might move this into a helper
function but i need to do
take the payload and loop through these
so payload
dot four each um
now i can do a map because i'm gonna
want
uh i can do an array instead of just
pushing individually
so let me take i don't know why i did it
this way but
okay so payload.map
and
i need to call a function which will be
entry and
basically going to take entry
dot doc
return entry dot doc
uh and i think that's what i want
let me see yeah that looks better anyway
and then so this is
so what bootstrap is doing is looking at
these first this first document and
saying okay
it has a name
um key and an id yeah i don't know why
this database is set up like this i
haven't read too much into it it just
looked like the best one out of all the
end of bjs options i saw um
but yeah the database table here is
taking the
names of just this first
item and then putting them in the header
but this one here with timestamps isn't
showing up so i need to
do some database cleanup first and let
me do that
here let me delete these two
entries that are just dummy entries
delete
okay so
and then also i'm wondering
yeah i'm wondering if key if i'm
supposed to be pulling
things out by key if i should be having
this as unique because it still has
a primary key here that is generating
for me
so yeah i'll have to read more about how
that works
but now i have start date and date so
if i refresh
oh let me reload app
wait exit
and now it's not
it's not showing anything hours log
um let me go to a different page and
navigate back
yeah it's not showing anything so
let me look at the view x store real
quick
and see what i have set time entries
i can refresh this
and
so why is it still i deleted them
directly from
here so i wonder
if i need to reset this
refresh index db
now let me try to reload this
okay it's not showing up at all now and
in my view
dev tools i have the same three time
entries that aren't supposed to exist
anymore
oh all right so oh these two are empty
now
and that other one's full that's why the
table's not showing up
because these first two
objects are empty
um yeah
and then this object isn't because
it was the only one that wasn't deleted
um so how do i fix this i guess i can
call just manually call a delete
delete document db.remove
and then the document id so let me call
this
just up here
so i guess i'll do time entries db
and just call it manually and i'll have
a vx action for this
at some point dot remove and then i need
to pass
in the
id of what the one i want to remove
um
that didn't seem to remove anything
though
maybe i need to restart the server let
me just
completely restart everything
new pouch db mydb destroy
okay i could call db.destroy let me if
this doesn't work i'm going to destroy
it
and it looks like it's not working yeah
it's not working
okay yeah until i have all my crud
operations set up
i'm just going to call
i'm just going to call destroy
destroy
can i do it on there
good sweet now let me do projects
okay cool so now they're both completely
refreshed
they didn't have the thanks for the help
sashi
they didn't have the edgy potato
breakfast bun i have no idea what that
is
i've had kolaches though i think aren't
they eastern european
or something
um when i was in serbia the person i
stayed with
fed me something like that so it might
not have been a kolache but it was
some kind of bread with a bunch of
flavorful stuff inside
um okay so now
if i go to view us there is zero chance
yes nothing there that's good
now i can add an actually valid time
entry
and date um
what date was that
722
and
do that submit
okay and now actually to pull i have to
go back here sweet so i have start date
end date
id and rev now the bootstrap table
is kind of annoying um
let me oh oops let me go here
and see bootstrap
egg oh eggy
i read that wrong iggy potato bun that
makes more sense for breakfast
not edgy potatoes
table table
tables
okay i'm using the table
and
pass in items
cell variance okay
column definition okay i can define
columns
so the fields prop
is used to customize the
table column headings in which order the
columns of data are displayed
okay that's good um
first name last name age
okay so now i need to pass in fields
which is an array of the titles that i
want
camel cased not camel case snake case
so let me go to my time
entry oh no it's the hours log this is
where the table is and
here so um
i'm doing okay let's actually
put these on different lines it's
starting to get long
and now i can pass in
um fields and i'm going to create a
fields array
for called fields
and so items i actually don't need items
anymore
but i do need fields
so this will be
start date and date so let me do start
date end
date
okay but it doesn't line up because i
think because the names aren't exactly
the same
so um oh yeah because these aren't snake
cased
they are camel cased so let me
line these up here then date
and date
that should yeah that worked okay and
then i just need moment
to format these dates a little bit
better let me go ahead and do that let
me install
moment um i'm going to add the name here
but that's only after i get the projects
all set up
so
lincoln park i haven't heard them in
forever um
okay i need to install moment.js so
moment
is that spell right moment yeah
all right
so now
this is weird because my little preview
still shows the
live in three minutes sign but the chat
is working fine
so okay
uh that's okay now i have a moment so
let me go ahead and do npm start
and
yeah run the app again and
now i can format these dates
so i'm going to create a function here
let's see um
time entry no an hour's log in mounted
no in methods i'm going to create a
method
so uh let's see
i'll just yeah i'll call it format date
format date
pass in a date and then i can return
moment dot oh i need to pass the date
into moment and then i can do dot format
and then say the format that i want
and let me import moment here before i
forget
so let me import moment
from moment
um and then format
month day
year um
[Music]
and then how do i put the
minutes like oh i think it's uh
minutes seconds something like that
and then am or pm
no wait this is hours i don't want
seconds uh
hours and then minutes that looks better
um oh yeah i'm not calling the function
yet i was like why aren't my dates
formatted
so let me go here and
oh hmm i'm gonna have to
format okay so this dot read time
entries
um how how am i going to do this because
i'm taking this directly from view x
from view x
so how am i going to format the dates as
they appear
here um
so i wonder should i use a slot like if
there are slots on the table
i don't know if bootstrap has anything
fancy like that
key um i could
map out the data
um
let's see fields primary key
let me search if they have a slot
used to trigger the display of row
details scope
slot
custom header and footer slots
um what about column slots there's
formatter
format or callback or the name of the
method in the component
and this is exactly what i want scoped
field slots the formatter will be called
with the syntax
formatter value
key item so
field definition reference
um so this is this is what i want but
then again
i'm pulling this in from view x so that
kind of has the same problem how do i
format what's coming in from view x
so should i use
um what should i use here should i use
computed maybe
a computed method
and watch
time entries basically i could call
the computed something like entries is
this what i should be doing
does anyone know what i'm talking about
so i could do something like entries
and
from here so from computed i don't think
i can call a method
but um
i can map the this dot time entries
right
uh yeah so i can do uh this dot time
entries
dot map and i'll return this
so this time entry stop map and then
entry and then when i'm looping through
it
i need to so let me return
the whole entry
except for
the times which is the whole entry um
yeah start date and date so
i'm gonna do overwrite start date
and and
date and these are going to be
format date ah okay
um so let me just try and see if it
works
i don't even know if this is the best
way i should be doing this
so date here will be
entry dot um
end date
and this will be start date
start date
okay
um oh yeah and then i have to take this
which is this entries method
and see if i can just loop through these
or no these will be the items in the
table now
okay cool that works anyway
um i'm not calling another method i
could just make this an external method
then
this format date one that's not in the
component
but yeah that works well this is a
a real time entry and i can add another
one
so let me add one here
let's see
let me add one here
and go to the hours log sweet and now i
have all of my
time entries that's pretty good
i have like 15 minutes left let me see
first of all when i add a new entry this
should really be routing back
yeah i'm happy about that i was nervous
at the at first because i was like oh no
i don't know how to
deal with databases and desktop apps but
it's not too bad uh after
figuring it out and i'm sure
i can just keep making it better and
tweaking it but overall it's
yeah pretty good let's see
um what was i just doing oh yeah i need
to route back
after i save
the entry so
i call on submit and i save it
and then
yeah using set set time entries
no no that's my mutation i'm doing
create time entry
and i save it here
so actually here
i should be let me
import my router here
import
from
a router because i have an index file in
my
router folder too okay so now i'm
importing router
and so i should be able to push
from here so i can do router.push
and what route do i want to go to
um let's see
which one oh yeah ours log
oh that's the home route okay well i'll
just push
um if i'm pushing by name oops what did
i just do
um if i'm pushing by name in the other
place
then i should probably do it by name
here too
so uh
ty no i can't i forgot already hours log
hours log
okay
all right so one more time entry for
two days ago i'll have to sort these
um based off of date too
oh come on it didn't push
um i wonder if that's because it's
submitting
yeah it was surprising i was worried
in the beginning because i kind of got
stuck and
yeah but i'm very happy with this
project
i'm actually excited about working on it
more
so let's see um
why isn't it pushing so on submit
am i actually doing a submit yeah this
is actually type submit so i think what
i need to do
is um maybe
e dot e dot prevent
default good
sashi d or sassy do you uh do any
desktop apps
or desktop app development
um let's see the 27th
we work till 10 pm submit
sweet do i have my i have my 27th there
great so i have my time entries now
um i wonder in the next like five
minutes or so
if i could just set up projects real
quick
so let me go here projects
and i've done applications using
swing i've never heard of that swing
in java so i guess that's a framework
for making desktop apps with java
don't forget to do commits and push yes
i won't
and last time i was in such a hurry i
force pushed and overwrote my readme
and had to hand type it out again
which was really dumb
um okay so project
now let me let me try to enter a project
real quick
get rid of all these time entry files
let's open project entry
and so i have on submit here so let me
do the prevent default before i forget
prevent default
okay and now i need to call
let me open my store
and i need to call this create project
um let's see yeah
and pass it the payload of the project
that i want to create
looks like it's set up already so i'll
just import
create project all right
[Music]
i'll have to call this dot create
project
and pass it a payload but first i need
to set up
view x so map actions
and i need the create project
action and then
oh wait
uh import um
map actions from
view x
okay and then this dot create project i
need to pass
in form data so i'm just going to pass
that in because that's already an object
so this dot form data
and that should work
so that's another thing i'll have to add
form validation next time too
so let me try typing in a name of a
project
let's say view
tracking app uh
our tracking app
built in view what color do i want
let's say orange
submit success
okay cool and now
i want to reroute
the same way i'm doing here so let me
just yank that
and push to wait push to
not hours log but projects
so let me push to projects
so let me create one more project and
i'll call this um
i don't know grid some
app so
let me say grid some blog choose a color
do blue that's a good color
submit cool so now i need to display the
projects
oh no because i was actually thinking
about having them in the drop down here
is that a good idea how many projects
are people gonna have
you know um oh well
i already have the drop down so might as
well keep it
but i need a getter though so
i have read time entries which gets all
the time entries
let me put
uh read projects here
read projects
and this will return
everything from the projects db
but i also need a different mutation
though so
set time entries i'm going to need set
projects here set
projects
[Music]
and what do i need here
okay so set projects state
payload and this will basically be the
same thing
from there um
exactly the same thing actually so
except this and it just keeps coming
back because i
every time i save it okay state.projects
this time i'm overwriting projects
payload entry entry.doc
that's all how the database data is set
up
so that's all fine
um set projects db projects okay
so read projects i'm going to have to
import this into my projects.view file
um okay i don't actually have
any script tag in here
so let me do
no i need computed here actually i
should have a name for the component
that would be
the best thing so it'll line up with
view router
called projects and now i'll do computed
and here is where i'm going to map state
which will be projects
projects okay and
i need to import map state so import
map state from
view x and
let's see
um map state no what am i doing it's not
projects
oh it is projects but i need it in the
array so projects
from state and now i have access to
this.projects
um but i need to get that
into state in the first place or the new
projects so i need a life cycle hook
here
so i'm going to use the mounted
lifecycle hook again
and call this dot
read projects to get those into state
i don't need to pass anything in
um but oh i need to
map that action so map actions
and that's going to have to be
inside of methods
so a methods object oops
um let's see
methods object and
that will be map actions
and then pass in
yeah read projects okay so now i can
call this.reprojects that should update
the projects there
and then i should be able to
use the array of projects here
to loop through select so i'm actually
going to have to use a computed here
to map these projects in the way that i
need them
but i'll have to look at how oh it says
payload is not defined
okay that must be where is that
um it's not giving me a file but i'm
guessing it's
let's see create
project read projects
docs dot rose
oh because there aren't any rows i think
and i'm calling reed projects with no
rows
um
so oh yeah and then i'm trying to so i
could do
i could do this uh
i think it's locked up oh no it's back
now
okay i could do this pass in an empty
array if there aren't any rows
payload is not defined where is payload
not defined
okay so it's saying
here um in set projects payload isn't
defined yeah and because i'm trying to
map through that payload
so let's see
but i think that this so doc's dot rose
or empty array i think that that will
fix the problem
um
oh it's still it's still doing that so
um yeah i don't know why the ore doesn't
work there
um but i have two minutes
yeah i do okay so
this line right here we have to fix this
line the error on this line
and be able to display projects on this
page
so if someone has an idea about that
after the stream then
let me know i am going to push my code
now
and if you want to check out uh more of
my live streams i do a lot of
vue.js live streams and django live
streams
on my channel which is faraday academy
i'm also on twitch
and you can find me there at faraday
academy on twitch
um oh thanks jared um let's see
i added db config which is empty it's
fine i'll leave it there
package lock public index i did update
those
okay that all looks good git commit dash
m is code from
live stream on july
31st today
okay let me push it
pull oh it's saying i'm not pull it oh i
think i updated the
readme maybe
yeah i updated the readme it's usually
what happens
in my own repels anyway okay
so i pushed and now you should be able
to see it
here
let's see oh yeah that's where i had to
rewrite the readme
last time after i force pushed
okay cool it has all of the updated code
what i'm gonna do is add a project board
here actually
for dev tasks and i'm going to fill this
out after the stream
but uh just to put all the things that i
still need to work on
on this app and add some columns here so
just so i can keep track of it because
it's getting to the point where
i can't just keep it in memory or figure
out what to work on next
so yeah if you have any uh feedback
suggestions feel free to
shoot me a message or to raise an issue
here or leave a comment if you're
watching this later
so yeah thanks for joining me today
uh have a great day everybody take care